اهلا جميلين اخباركم ان شاء الله بخير
رجعتلكم من جديد انا انجود
شمري في ناس كثير بحياتنا نحبهم في ناس
كثير بحياتنا ونا نسعدهم لو شي بسيط شلون
نقدر نسعد هذول الناس انا اقدر اسعدهم اي
يهمك انت يهم كل بنت انا انت كل بنت في
العالم انا من كل قلبي اتمنى ان كل امراه
في العالم تكون قويه اللي ما يعرف ليش انا
فاتحه القناه عشان اوريكم حياتي واقول لكم
عن مواضيع صارت لي اقوللكم ماذا في حقيبه
المدرسه او اهم اساسيات حقيبه المدرسه
شوفوا حقيبتي كيف حلوه هلا والله طبعا راح
نجيب اول شي كلامين فسفوري انا ما ادري
تسمونهم انتم ماها الوان
[موسيقى]
فسفوريه اق اطق قول
شي يعني تاج
[موسيقى]
تاج لا لا مو حركه فانتستيك توقف غلط دبل
باركين لا في كثير عندنا بنات بالنسبه لهم
التطوع اني اخذ صاحباتي واروح ونفلها
وماعرف ايش وما نقدم شيء والطريقه الثالثه
طبعا هي حلوه ليش لانه فيها زي ما قلت لكم
الوان الكل في الوان بس هذه فيها تزيين
الغرفه تقدرون تزينون الغرفه وذ الاشياء
بعد ما خلصنا اكل جينا ناخذ ارواج شوفوا
هذا
الروج ساره مختاره هذا الروج حبيتيه ساره
بناخذ هذا ايش يعني احنا طالعين نتغدا
بالكين نطلع نتغدا ما
يحتاج
لكن انا كثير حلو وبالنسبه لي هذه طريقه
الاسعاد من حاولي جذا ما ادري وين كان
عقلي وانا قاعده اكتب بكل مكان الجيمز
المنتديات اللي كنت
[موسيقى]
ادخلها قبولاتي لكم احبكم احبكم احبكم انا
احبكم